hey guys it's eric here welcome to a now
playing of infinity wars i'm actually
joined here by Elfie coil chairman of
light mara studio is also the creator of
infinity ward's thank you for joining me
today Elfie thanks it's good to have you
right so why don't we jump in and you
can tell me all about it awesome awesome
so just to take it from the very top
infinity wars is traditional trading
card game you completely reimagined for
the digital free-to-play formats of pc
mac android and iOS so the key features
and the key points of difference is that
every card is fully animated there's
factions from the Star Trek universe
which is the big announcement we've been
making recently as well as full open to
Player to Player trading as and the big
one is another big one is on that we
have different modes in the game that
completely eliminate the concept of
pay-to-win which is a big complaint of
trading card games in general and we
also have simultaneous turns so both
players are taking the terms at the same
time there's no waiting for the other
player to make them moves the game is
much faster and it has a much more
integrated pace and it also opens up the
concept of bluffing protection mechanics
which is cool and then every animated by
every battlefield we have is the fully
3d as well so there's different modes
and battlefields you can change on the
fly so that you know the concept is that
you can concert conquer these parallel
reality realities with or against your
mates even has a right now because it's
currently on Steam early access awesome
awesome so you know why don't you show
me how the game plays or you know show
me you know a deck or something
something cool sure so having a look at
the game here what we can do is we have
a quick squiz at the like the the basic
mechanics of the game i could take
people through so a few of them you know
if you're a player who's played any kind
of trading card games and this will make
sense i'll be moving at a pace that sort
of makes sense for anyone who's familiar
with something like for example magical
you give any of those traditional
trading card games which is what we've
built infinity wars on but as i said
before completely really designed it for
the digital format so what you see here
is this is
I don't the audio is coming through
right so okay yep the lovely lady here
talking over the top as well but we'll
do our best to work with that so in
infinity wars the idea is to take us
take the opponent's health or morale
down to zero there's two different modes
of basically winning the game will cover
what morale is in a moment so at the
bottom of the screen that have a hand so
we can have a look at these cards I can
just touch any of these cards he'll
bring it up on screen we can see that
every card is beautifully animated in
some form I like this guy here we can
have a look at this other one yeah
awesome I'm i play this guy up okay so
key thing is she's been making home
moves at the same time as I have been
and it's nearly press and turn and we
watched as the two sides have their
actions and planned actions resolve all
the ones and since the start of turn 2
i'll just drawn a new card and we can
see here that he's played out a soldier
of fortune sorry she's played at a
soldier fortune and i now have two
resources so the web source curve works
there's no amount of a no- crew who
essentially every turn you get an extra
maximum resource in which to play your
hand out winco up to a maximum of 10
naturally then so we have a look here
with a to resources suspend I can just
pop two of these things out instead now
when they come out they come out into
the support zone which is essentially
where they need to come out for a term
before they usually used kind of like
summoning sickness satellite daddy and
then from there there's actually four
different main zones that a bit of
different infinity ward's to any other
trading card game and this allows for
positional combat tactics which as a
whole nother layer of depth to the game
itself I can now take my guy who's free
to ready rock and do something and put
him either into the defense zone to
defend this turn or into the assault sir
so
aggressive player so I'm going to go
straight for assault and then we'll see
what happens again it's a reminder that
this thing this game only has
essentially four main things that
happens enjoy cards plan out your all
your movements then the resolution phase
and everything happens that was planned
out on both sides and layers in to be
planned out and then we have the end of
the term right so we're going to see
what she's done and she's going to
defend whilst I've gone to attack now
these moves are all made in secret
people don't know what's going to happen
and so we'll see some good examples of
what can happen as a result of that
later on so combat resolves and we have
persistent damage and health so the five
attack I have went off his seven health
bringing him down to two and here's to
how attack damage has come off my health
bringing me down to two out of four just
click that away next turn cool tech
night ok now I'm going to spend all
three resources bring hear me out okay
and make some more choices around where
I want to put my people now obviously
this combat happens again that to damage
will come up my to health from the first
flame dawn aspirant sorry for men and NM
kill him so what i can do is i can
rearrange my guys I know he's going
first combat resolves left to right and
we'll see what happens so that's also
another cool thing that the game has
because it's online the persistent
damage actually shows and it stays
unlike you know if you're playing you
know in person kind of you know either
have to write it down or yeah little
tokens on there none of that stuff and
that's the beautiful thing about having
a table format game just good like that
killed him off great my guys still alive
now there's no defenders left so all the
rest of the damage will go straight on
to the fortress you can say 100 health
goes down by nine and he gets smacked
around a little bit easier than 88
health okay so we're going to do see a
couple of things right now we're going
to see how ability cards work
and we're also going to see some bluffin
prediction mechanics will be in this
case a prediction mechanic happen so a
leader is going to put out her massive
defender 0-25 defense column now I can
tell obviously it's of Defense Golan
right so it's highly unlikely she's
going to attack with this guy which is
probably going to do with them at the
end of the turn is put him in the
defense center she knows what's good for
ya so what i can do is i can cut her off
at the pass and get ok you're probably
going to put that defense ball into the
defense zone i have this cool ability
called stumble that costs one I can see
Matt operating corner return target
character in a combat zone to its
controllers support zone so it'll shove
it right back as soon as it tries to go
out if it tries to go out if she doesn't
try to put it out I've just wasted a
card and wasted my resource that's the
the risk reward ok of plank making this
kind of play even without knowing where
it is at the time so I'm just going to
target the defense golden and I'm going
to bank that she's going to do that so
I'm going to go all out on the attack
not have any defenses mm-hmm also kind
of beating her into playing the Golem to
write because you're gonna you're
representing a lot of damage there
exactly but yeah she all she can see
currently she can't see that third but
that fourth guy because she knows that
this three guys there from last turn so
she's probably going to make that play
I've got two more resources to spend and
nothing else I can do it in my turn and
we'll see yep she's done that so that's
paid off in a way stumble flicks him
back to the support zone and then all
that damage hits through just did 20
damage yes ok turn five now commanders
is a very important part of this
individuals and one of the key things
that make it a very different experience
to many other trading card games the
reason being you can choose when we
designed this in the first place the
idea is you know we get attached certain
characters we love the idea of having a
certain guys on our side and we want to
be able to draw that person every time
so what we've done is when we when you
first create a deck you choose your
commanders you choose up to three
commanders and then they sit in the
command zone those commanders can be
used for the abilities while they're in
the command zone and they can also be
dragged straight out onto the
battlefield so there's
summoning sickness essentially for these
guys it's two benefits of having me
commanders and the other cool thing is
actually determined the factions of the
person plays with so like the colors
they determine what we are allowed to
play with what cards you can have your
deck legally so whacking this guy out
bromwich field commander he gives when
he's in the assault sir and it gives
ball other attacking players plus 2 plus
0 which is kind of cool now there is
like four guys here right so I can take
a bit of a risk here and just go all out
in this case I'm probably going to
actually put maybe this guy because he
regenerates into the defense zone okay I
see how he goes obviously if it goes all
out then he's going to disadvantage to
me but you might want to stop some of
the stuff coming through so just do a
little rearranging and off we go let's
see what happens is there a maximum
amount of units you can put into either
zone isn't a maximum thanks add there
are cards that bring out every single
beast in play can your deck into play
for example I think it's kind of messy
but it's fun messy okay so we're going
to see here that we've it took three
hits two take out that defense column
right so the defense attorney will sit
there and defend every single attacker
from left to right until it dies gotcha
in this case it's going to kill off the
end drone and my character and boom okay
so yes going forward and attacked on the
other end so but only with two
characters so my tech night is going to
survive and hold the foot so the
animated battle for sorry 3d
battlefields we have here as well so
there's a fire the fortress of dawn you
can see so you know full 3d battlefield
looks kind of cool doesn't awesome stuff
because you can only have one out in
this case it basically creates a free
warrior every single turn on the on the
battlefield okay and so this should
almost bring it home we should be able
to do pretty well here
it's about all I can do this turn serves
press in turn okay and we'll see a big
metal come back they're bringing him
down to third 237 okay so just to let
you guys know I mean obviously there's
some pretty simple cars will be seeing
so far key point of our game as well as
that we make sure that with increased
rarity that doesn't become increased
necessarily power but it makes it a more
complicated card berth some potential
you know to do some pretty interesting
things so in this case we have agent
called fire started with some pretty
gorgeous animation and he's got an
ability called charge so you go straight
to the assault zone can also evolve and
to transform into a different card
attacks three times every turn and can
evolve into a 2424 flying unstoppable
dragon that will attack please and I
notice that's a legendary so okay yeah
makes sense say yeah and you know it
might seem like a more powerful but
there's a morale costs to 12 so when you
lose a character you lose morale that's
an alternate wind condition essentially
if you get in zero morale you lose the
game see losing him will cost quite a
bit of morale 12 in this case what's the
page 12 is at peace while morale or an
old resources Oh resources manager so
how'd you get the toilet how do you get
to 12 through different cards you can
have and there's also a thing called the
Trading Post which will take a look at
in the second game Austin and we'll see
how we can get above 10 resources it's
going to do you don't want to lose this
guy because his buff will go
a little bit like that and then
hopefully this will bring it home the
hem and metric ton of damage 65 manage
let it I'm kind of glad it didn't go to
cycle through each attack animation
there because it's like okay yeah nice
the Polish thanks to the beta testers
have been helping us out along the way
actually a research change you used to
have to cook forever but now it's yeah
pretty good so that's the first game of
infinity ward's which we've won and then
we're going to take a quick look now at
the at the Star Trek announcement and
then another a game just have a look at
a couple different things so stately win
so you get free cards from every way it
can free cars from playing the game in
the campaign for playing can say I for
logging into the game on today for
winning three times or place are playing
three games and you get you get that as
well so you kind of have multiple like
quests or multiple adventures that kind
of go through to earn your cards when
you earn the cards is it is it possible
to get something like that legendary
from doing some of these kind of side
side quests or missions or um yeah
absolutely you can get whole packets of
cards from doing from doing you know all
these different missions and side quests
and you know as a fool there's a hundred
and twenty something quests as well so
there's like a lot to be able to explore
in the game from the back end so kind of
a quick look at the the new Star Trek
cards and then finally we'll learn well
why don't we pick the early going okay
okay so this is the the new Star Trek
release so we can have a look at those
cards they're looking pretty sweet and
you know hopefully bring in a bunch of
people who are and to start dragging
into strategy of some kind and because
there's so much more enjoyment if one
can get it in actually understanding a
trading card game and then if one not
one did you just press the button over
and I mean I spoke with you earlier and
out you know in terms of balance and and
adding the coolness of the Star Trek
element to it and you're telling me you
know of course you guys try to do your
best to balance around for the game so
you know it'll be fun for the players to
see how this faction plays out yeah
really USS Enterprise the cards man was
proud of very nice very nice ok so let's
have a look at just will jump in this
won't actually finish this match but I
want to do a riff fun with us if we can
chuckles quick squeeze at
so the one thing pop out of zero cost
Tribble just for fun having look at the
trading post this is one of the things
we've used to deal with the concept of
dead drawing so when you have a whole
dead turn because you drew a car that
wasn't good when you've got maximum
resources you can choose to pay some of
the resources to shuffle to get some
card draw and happening to pay three to
shuffle card back into the deck and draw
a card pay five to draw a card pay nine
to increase space resources by one to go
above 10 and then that that persists
through the next round the plus one yep
okay max an extra maximum resource
absolutely and does that have a limit
there's never limit okay the right cold
cuts across something like 15 resources
actually yeah so the mechanics are going
to be pretty much the same in the second
game so rather than then we're in the
viewers were seeing the same thing again
they can always download it and play it
gorham and we'll just jump out of this
match and I'll start to show you riff
from what we have a little bit of a
conversation sure in general some
questions yeah so I noticed right away a
difference already from this starting
hand versus or not just a hand with this
the field that you have three commander
cards already there whereas previously
you didn't have it is true into it is
that just part of the system or a
tutorial just because okay a concept of
having these three commanders kind of
the most people for the first time they
ever played the game but as of your
second game on Windows is always three
commanders gotcha and how many
commanders do you roughly have I guess
perfection because it's faction based
are any character any character moving
odd can be chosen as a commando oh wow
okay yeah and then yeah like you
mentioned before if I have like an
ability that activates or something like
taps essentially yeah they can use that
ability from command zone
so what we're looking at now is a riff
front so we're going to have a look at
the one of the modes in the game that
really evens up the whole idea of being
played paid pay-to-win weather yeah we
do it away with with a mode like this in
which a player will create their deck
from scratch from a bunch of packets and
then play with that dick with other
people who have made their deck from
scratch from a bunch of packets the cool
thing about this and key point of
difference i will put a head on this one
is that at the end of your roof run you
can actually choose to purchase that
dick Wow okay so if you if you felt like
it won a bunch of times and you kind of
got attached to it you're like hey I
want that deck so now I'm gonna buy it
okay that's kind of cool i like that and
even better is that if you play well
with the deck and you've actually done
well with it before you want dick gonna
get a discount on that deck as well ok
as a reward ok to the point where you
can actually win a minute Nick for free
oh wow ok how many wins does that take
like 20 or 30 oh wow that's ok through
that that's cool I like that there's no
like cap of winds kind of like Arsenal
and like you kind of hit the 12 most
like ok that's it I make another one
right that that's cool we like having
like little like we wanted to step into
eSports as well so we're doing a bit of
like mini 20s and serve food Oh interest
last refrain count for the weekend gets
a mess set of person is there gonna be
some type of like leaderboard okay yes
yes and there is already currently
leader bullets for from full ranked mode
normal constructed for elderly as well
so I ranked mode and Rick runs so we can
do here is we can choose our commanders
we're now a key point is that the card
has purity right so essentially each of
these cards will determine how many and
what type of cuts you can have in your
deck both the factions they come from
and then the power of a particular card
in a particular faction so in this case
we can see that there's two symbols at
the top there which means it requires to
Genesis industry commanders to be
included in the deck all right okay so
we're going to do that which means we
can now have one and two costs or wanted
to purity sorry Genesis cards and we'll
also go
something like just for the sake of
difference will go the Royal kidnapper
okay that faction so there's currently
seven factions in the game with more
launched on a regular basis obviously
the two star trek factions are coming in
in a couple of weeks time when when the
pre-orders go to full release and
essentially you know all those cards
will be usable in the game now one of
the key points is that you know the Star
Trek cars currently are not going to be
accessible in rain to modem professional
play okay yeah we'll see how it all goes
if we get enough demand I don't see any
reason why we won't do that if if people
really want that so the people need a
voice they do then cake up and support
this book the concept so having a look
here we've got a secluded constructor
there are gold and foil cards we have
some level of premium yes and we can
just go through and literally just
choose much of guys to make a deck we
have a match yeah so so do you have
multi factions in this as you draft like
you're not kind of stuck in one faction
right yeah well you have whatever
factions you chose as you come on okay
in this case that is into the blue the
Genesis industries and then the rule
sort of Death Magic people ok so then
within this draft now you can either
choose from either those factions are
like neutral position factions or merged
faction so there might be like a hybrid
you have a rule and Genesis character
that could come up here
I'm putting very little food into my
cuts I'm picking the shiny ones and the
ones that look this that's not going to
bode well a little bit maybe I'll just
I'll play them anyways yeah so I you
know like we see the the power curve
which is called your resource curve does
as you're drafting or as you're going
through this rift run does it do the
cards that show up start to help you
build out your curve or you have to kind
of be careful about how you look at our
example they're very random but just
within that that particular faction so
you get what you choose end of the day
and the stack is a 40 cards I belief
aside 40 card is minimum def get 33 of
each cutters and then us are three of
each character is this point and spell
is the maximum you can happen in attack
and so it's worth you know talking about
how long they just normally go for and
we have typically 10 to 15 minutes for a
match it's a good good pace like a good
speed I think a lot of people don't
having a 30 or 45 minutes to spend like
you know so getting a lot of games
within an hour is always good it is not
shown each item to get the artwork looks
amazing though he's a good job to the
game yeah you can definitely see even
the death ray that's pretty decent but
we the guys have been working on an
Africa 15 months so they're getting
better and better by the day and the
partnership we're really thankful for
CBS you know having you know such high
standards for their art as well so it
takes it takes a while sometimes to get
it across the line which just raises the
skill of the players even sorry over the
pharmaceutical yep and so for those who
don't know we are actually at like a
fully india company so there's any eight
devs that are on board and you know
we're growing a little bit by the day
because we're getting more attention
for any product that sounds good we able
to do this playthrough right now this
will be a lot of people who have never
seen this game still definitely I mean
even for myself you know it's the first
time I've seen it so it's looking good
you know I've come you know from the
back in the day when magic and you know
am playing Arsenal now so the card games
you know popularity have kind of seen a
surge lately and it's kind of cool to
see like a variant like this you know
with a different play style but kind of
still having some of the core you know
trading card aspect to it and of course
as you said earlier you know being a
trading card game thank God you know
like I want to be able to like if you
know have a couple friends you know they
want to play specific deck or something
I can be like hey I'm not gonna use this
like powerful legendary what do you have
so that that can help me out you know
like I like the whole bartering system
with trading was like really cool to me
because it was always like hey I have
this one and you really want it so now
that I know you really want it you might
give me two or three cards instead of
you know so just another layer on top of
again yeah unless at the end of the
selection process so
it's another couple points of difference
if we've got as a game is that with a
weekly new cards so every single week
there's something called the check out
something new to check out it can be
played and earned through playing the
missions of the game so you don't have
access to them right away if they're
like your mission to get them or it will
come PS IM going cuz this new there's
new quests that come out and then those
quests unlock brand new cards so we're
going to play our practice match against
the bots and how gonna get owned on TV
oh so you can do the riff run and play
against sequently I hurry I can stay on
absolutely Wow why we want people to
play reference cuz we love them so when
we good oh the dealing for damage type
of character I don't like this commander
over here it's very scary she can
actually go and sacrifice cards to make
other cards bigger and give them plus
one plus one so I'm just going to deal
with it instantly okay so that basically
if you have an ability card you can
pretty much target for commanders right
off the bat and the only a physically
cut some guy ability cards any target
battlefield astute if there's three
different areas is like battlefield
which includes the support so there's
combat zones which is the assault and
defense and then the commander's own
separate to all of that concurrently
they're generally very protected the
commanders are most protected support
after that and then the comet
intercourse healthy so
yeah this bot has got you know I'm going
to play a location pretty fun location
every turn it a little shuffle all my
cards every every time you give me a new
set keep it interesting fresh that's a
world play what if there's something in
your hand that you really like good day
does that affect the other player as
well as it just for yourself message
okay I just curious because I noticed it
showed up on a battlefield with location
so remove target character from the game
alright so I look let's kidnap her out
move that one out
just getting this horde of unending
drones kidnapper see you later check on
entirely I'm just till he dies oh and
he's almost daddy's on one health so
they'll miss the most perfect yeah I can
switch him up move it and pop him in the
ass all set to what happens six
resources have to play a couple of
things and
give him a jetpack we might wear as a
jetpack what motivates do sounds fun
yeah should talk your character flying
okay he seems quite happy about his
jetpack I would be too man yeah this way
hope don't in turn yet five volts to use
a nice always get to have spells just
pop a couple of those fireballs out so
have any more on an endurance coming for
sorry I kind of missed it but when you
use the spells was there kind of like
the is that what you wanted to do versus
like oh that's not what I wanted to
target kind of thing okay we did it okay
Red Cross say that comes up and it's
like just want to make sure there was
like oh i fat fingered it and like I
didn't mean to shoot it over there
wonderfully this is this thing that
we've actually put in the game called an
undo button oh really annoyed me playing
other trading card games recently not
being able to do that yeah I wish I kind
of get used to that mechanic it's hard
to kind of turn back yeah it was like a
magic is like hold on to it do I wanna
bring a packet so he's done cool create
a copy when he's removed from the game
okay I don't know I'll just plain that
because he's got an attack
no you're going to lay the beating down
now you know bring it home
ok
so what else leave that um yeah just
want to reiterate that you know we're
really thankful for the support we've
been getting so far from originally from
a Kickstarter backers and then we see
through the beta we've been going pretty
strong and the game is quite a bit
through beta now so that's almost ready
to ready to rock you guys have a long
thick we don't have a launch it except
it is gonna be the next couple of months
so awesome hopefully should be in the
next that's and that one's pc mac first
right yeah we're going pc mac first but
the mobile companion that we have coming
out which has a lot of the [ __ ] we call
it companion because it has a lot of the
functions of the full game but not
necessarily wall oven okay but you can
you know play with your deck anyway that
is coming out in the next couple almost
in the next month or so i'm going to
have that okay so that's that would be
after at least I made us okay everyone
can be able to access it at that point
yeah taking out damage and
which reduces power tech and toughness
to 21 pop out the scouting ship off we
go should bring it home
nerf the crap out of that guy plus four
plus four well it's a good thing you
answer interesting to note here is that
it's you know the way that the combat
works in the way that the turn order
works because i had initiative each
player has initiative each alternatively
then my abilities golf before his so
because he I'd had initiative my ability
when i'll first and then he's him back
up to 55 okay and what determines who
has initiative first i guess it starts
randomly okay gotcha okay so i'm going
to see a split a rebel how'd my take on
this board one ending drones left or
right bison it up though yeah he is and
then he splits into two wow that's what
what you guys boom GG easy peasy yuri on
that one so we're probably just finally
have a look at video yeah let's have a
look at the shop yeah sure okay just
finished a place
while we're visiting the shop ok cool so
this is the shop you can buy obviously
cards packets for both in-game currency
and for premium currency and then with
that stuff you can trade away and decks
pre-made x there's a whole bunch of
premium content for those who want to
support us more and union look sometimes
card backs for premium currency and
extra bit of default battlefields you
can do the three orders as well yeah so
sonu earn currency for the game where do
you just earn the packs you currency
through the game and nobody's has been
the in-game currencies of the Infinity
points and how fast do you think that is
it's it's reasonably fast the key thing
is we look up to fight new players ok
when you level up you get a free packet
of cards so it's quite easy level for a
while you get quite a solid connection
you cook us our collection in quite a
partial period of time I guess I guess
the next question is it what is 300
currency in regards to like a dollar
amount yeah so it works it to be about a
double 20 full 100 points ok an hour is
there like some type of bigger package
of like if you spend X amount you get
like even more points yeah you just all
the way up Sophie some people ok and I
guess the last question the most
important question is if let's say I'm
in the office and I'm playing someone
that I know is going to spend a lot of
money he's gonna go and I don't know
throw like three hundred dollars like
right off the bat and I'm you I decide
you know let me feel this game out I
want to play it I want to earn some of
my cards my own way yeah what is my
chance against ya beating him if he
spends three hundred dollars because a
lot of people's fears like pay to win
right like if I'm gonna run into a deck
I'm gonna run into a monster that's not
gonna be fun right yeah I get rolled so
I'll handle that so what I would do and
what I love playing is when we've had
this in the game since alpha is a
concept called merge deck mode so you
can just set up a merge dick game invite
him to your move tech game and he brings
us $400 there keep bringing a 50 50 cent
deck and then and then what happens it
takes all those guys and shuffles them
up oh wow and you draw from the same car
pool
it really does come down to he's got
that most skill I'm awesome in a bit of
luck enjoying the ride okay so let my
friend spend the money and then we'll
play together and then I get to I get to
play his cards ya did it off you can go
do all that and and you enjoy all that
that's a really cool one yeah alright
well you know why don't you remind the
folks you know like when roughly the
game's gonna come out what platforms and
anything else you want to say them so
the key thing is to go to wpa infinity
wars calm and and actually jump in and
grab an account the pre order should be
live as of this going live so get some
cards if you want to or just enjoy the
game and look forward to you know
hanging out with you guys we just want
to build the absolute best game we can
make and we're quite confident that we
can do that now we've got a solid game
with great mechanics and a bunch of cool
artist I've been doing really well and
now we've got a great brand with with
Star Trek coming into infinity wars and
the options are quite endless there when
it comes to bed as well so I just want
to create the biggest like all-out brawl
of infinity wars that we can and so yeah
welcome everyone support and look
forward to seeing you guys in the forms
an in-game awesome thanks so much for
the demo today and I hope you guys you
know check it out and try it out and
yeah yes thanks eric and thanks to the
love yous and yeah see great cheese
you